[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
todo listo para un nuevo intento de
diálogo para ponerle fin a la crisis en
venezuela las delegaciones de nicolás
maduro y juan guaidó confirmaron su
participación en las negociaciones con
sede en méxico y con mediación de
noruega asediado por las denuncias de
acoso sexual en su contra el gobernador
de nueva york andrew cuomo renunció sin
embargo no reconoció la responsabilidad
en los casos que atribuyó a diferencias
generacionales
y en argentina solo se habla del fichaje
de lionel messi por parte del paris
saint german nuestro equipo en buenos
aires habló con los porteños y nos
cuenta qué opinan de la salida del
barcelona del 6 veces ganador del balón
de oro a mejor jugador
y la quinta será la vencida méxico acoge
las conversaciones entre las
delegaciones de nicolás maduró y el
opositor juan guaidó con miras a ponerle
fin a la crisis que atraviesa venezuela
con esta decisión el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador se aleja de la
posición de los países que integran el
grupo de lima que no reconocen al
gobierno de maduro la voluntad del
mandatario mexicano que cuenta con la
mediación de noruega no representa una
tarea fácil desde la muerte del
presidente hugo chávez en 2013 maduro y
distintos representantes de la oposición
han intentado negociar al menos cuatro
veces
las protestas en rechazo al gobierno de
nicolás maduro que en 2014 conmocionaron
al mundo por la cruda represión que dejó
al menos 43 muertos y cientos de heridos
y detenidos dieron paso al primer
intento las conversaciones se llevaron a
cabo en el palacio de miraflores en
caracas pero terminaron sin acuerdos en
noviembre de 2016 la oposición impulsó
un referendo revocatorio en contra de
nicolás maduro lo que los llevó a
sentarse de nuevo en caracas para
discutir sobre la situación de los
presos políticos la crisis económica y
la escasez de alimentos y medicinas
varios ex presidentes de américa latina-
unasur y el vaticano me dieron en el
diálogo que también terminó entre
acusaciones mútuas de incumplimientos
tras las renovadas protestas en contra
de nicolás maduro y el llamado de la
oposición a unas elecciones libres y
justas se convocó a una nueva mesa de
diálogos esta vez en república
dominicana
pero la tercera no fue la vencida y
termino con un receso indefinido
el último intento fue en 2019 con dos
cds oslo en noruega y barbados la
delegación de maduro se retiró de la
mesa por las sanciones impuestas por
eeuu en contra de él y sus allegados
nosotros la patria vamos a eeuu para
revisar la imagen de la semana ella es
kathy hochul la nueva gobernadora de
nueva york quien asumirá el cargo tras
la renuncia de andrew cuomo en medio de
las acusaciones de acoso sexual en su
contra cocula adelantó que dejara fuera
del equipo de gobierno a cualquiera que
esté relacionado con esas conductas a
mary quiero que la gente sepa que estoy
lista para esto no es algo que esperara
o que pidiera pero estoy totalmente
preparada para asumir las
responsabilidades como 57º gobernadora
del estado de nueva york nadie que
aparezca en el reporte y que haya hecho
algo poco ético se quedará en mi
administración
la renuncia de como llega luego de que
perdiera el apoyo de todo su partido
incluso del presidente joe biden y se
comenzará a hablar de un juicio político
en la asamblea de nueva york con miras a
su destitución sin embargo hay críticas
por la forma en la que se llevó a cabo
ya que nunca reconoció su
responsabilidad que fue corroborada por
la fiscalía tras las denuncias de 11
mujeres
el gobernador de nueva york andrew cuomo
finalmente se dio a la presión y
renunció aunque no reconoció su
responsabilidad en los once
señalamientos de acoso sexual que pesan
en su contra y que la fiscalía confirmó
y
asumo toda la responsabilidad por mis
acciones
he sido muy familiar con las personas mi
sentido del humor puede ser insensible
mi renuncia será efectiva en 14 días a
mi equipo gracias gracias las mujeres
que acusaron al demócrata se declararon
aliviadas de que como ya no esté en una
posición de poder para herir a otras
mujeres pero cuestionaron el hecho de
que se excusara en que se trata de un
supuesto malentendido
creo que la respuesta de cómo es
terrible y peligrosa es anacrónico que
siga diciendo que esto es un asunto
generacional a menos de que tuviera como
85 porque un hombre de sesenta y tantos
que ha estado en la política durante 40
años esto no es generacional hemos
hablado de acoso sexual desde hace tres
décadas y nunca ha estado bien
como había sido gobernador de nueva york
que por tres mandatos y se ganó el
respeto de los simpatizantes demócratas
al impulsar medidas progresistas con el
tiempo se había convertido en una de las
figuras demócratas más aclamadas y un
potencial candidato a la casa blanca
pero su reputación comenzó a decaer lo
acusaron de haber ocultado la muerte por
kobe de varias personas en asilos de la
ciudad por ahora una mujer que lo señala
de haberla manoseado ya presentó una
denuncia criminal en su contra en el
estado de nueva york
y seguimos con más información de eeuu
el senado aprobó el plan de
infraestructura del presidente joe biden
el proyecto que se espera financiar a la
renovación de vías puertos puentes entre
otros aún debe ser aprobado por la
cámara de representantes- una gran
victoria para el presidente
norteamericano yo bailé en esta votación
los 169 los 9 30 se aprueba el proyecto
de ley con las enmiendas tras el masivo
plan de infraestructura fue aprobado por
el senado
después de años de debilidad estamos en
el auge de la década de la
infraestructura que realmente creo que
va a transformar a eeuu transformar
1.2 billones de dólares han sido
avalados para renovar carreteras puentes
puertos y aeropuertos pero también para
los circuitos de agua potable y
electricidad y para renovar el internet
de alta velocidad
550 mil millones de dólares serán
inyectados en nuevos gastos federales
aún por definir otros
450 mil millones de fondos ya están
atribuidos a otras partidas un día antes
el secretario de estado anthony blinken
había llamado la atención sobre la
importancia de aprobar este plan
nos estamos quedando atrás del mundo y
nuestros rivales lentamente se están
acercando a nosotros joven shows fijados
en summer y en algunas áreas ya están
por delante en desmedro es importante
porque si esta tendencia continúa
seremos menos competitivos en un mundo
más competitivos en mortimer world el
plan es el fruto de un raro consenso
entre demócratas y republicanos la
próxima batalla de bailén será la
inversión de 3.500 millones de dólares
en infraestructura humana por eso
necesitaría aumentar impuestos sobre
sociedades sin seguridad de que sea
aprobado
y como una afrenta consideró el gobierno
de alberto fernández la designación de
ahmad vahidi como ministro del interior
de irak el general iraní es acusado por
la justicia argentina de ser uno de los
autores intelectuales del atentado a la
sede de la asociación mutual israelita
argentina amia en buenos aires que dejó
85 muertos en 1994 bási tiene desde 2007
un pedido de captura internacional el
centro de la comunidad judía en buenos
aires- también repudió su nombramiento
y sigamos en argentina porque hasta allí
llegó la fiebre del psg tras la
contratación de la estrella del fútbol
lionel mesi nuestro equipo en buenos
aires recogió las reacciones de sus
compatriotas sus mayores fans en el
siguiente informe en las calles de
buenos aires la noticia de la llegada de
lionel messiah parís está en boca de
todos los periódicos y a la anunciaron y
los canales de televisión sólo hablan
del niño amado de argentina es el único
tema del momento que preocupa a los
porteños
es una escena tradicional en buenos
aires entre viajes los taxistas suelen
tomarse un café en general les gusta el
fútbol
ellos son incluso ex futbolistas semi
profesionales y messi es importante para
ellos
estamos viendo si se queda en el
barcelona si se va al parís para
nosotros para el argentino es muy
importante queremos que juegue en algún
país no sé no importa donde donde esté y
que juegue conduciendo por las calles de
la capital héctor intenta explicar esta
pasión argentina y porque es una forma
para él de sobrellevar su vida cotidiana
acá nos estamos olvidando de la política
de lo que pasa con la pandemia y no se
habla de otra cosa que no es de messi
igual somos raros no son vendidos
entre los más jóvenes meses o incluso
más grande que maradona estos profesores
de gimnasia son fans absolutos él genera
esa angustia cuando él está mal nosotros
estamos mal alegría y él llega vamos a
parar alegres por él por su familia
porque es nada completo nos llena todos
los aspectos lo vamos a seguir prestando
a messina da al mundo para que siga
brillando porque es nuestra es argentina
y américa latina está en vilo por la
salud de vicente fernández el reconocido
cantante mexicano fue intervenido
quirúrgicamente al sufrir un accidente
en su rancho de guadalajara sus médicos
descartaron daño cerebral me despido con
la música del rey de la ranchera soy
natalia cabrera pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas en la producción estuvo joan y
el modelo
como sostiene
pero me llegó el mover
pero
[Música]
y hago caso al corazón
vivo el verbo
muy bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
otra vez
[Música]
[Aplausos]